[Music]
right through the city like British I'm
on a mission to get it all right through
the city like British if you ain't thick
please don't get involved
now Brandon
what is
that jam they uh what's up guys how's
everybody doing welcome this Monday
September 12th and
um I am fresh off the plane from
Appleton Wisconsin not easy get to
happen in Wisconsin especially when I
have a layover in Chicago and Chicago
said we're gonna have a typhoon and uh
make your flight delay to miss your
layover then you hang out all day with
your friend Mark in the airport so
that's what we did but we made it dude
that's part of the game that's part of
that airport game daddy so uh yeah man
what can you do had a great time in
Appleton uh small little town I love
those small towns I just I love it don't
know if I could live there but
everyone's so nice
um Appleton about 30 minutes from Green
Bay listen I don't know Wisconsin any
faster so I learned things when I get
into town and uh
you know that's why he's on the show
yeah
um
the thing is about uh Wisconsin is
everybody super nice uh cheese curds are
their thing right and they're pretty
good we had some good cheese curds
there's some good little local
restaurants and coffee out there which
is all I care about
um they do a lot of things that I feel
like are gonna make you shoot your pants
cheese curds and then uh fans would buy
me I took I don't several of them you
would take a shot of tequila and then
Chase it with pickle juice oh yeah
you've heard of that yeah I've never
heard of that I've done it it's good
really oh I did not like it did not
enjoy it and cheese curds and then
pickle juice with tequila you're just
trying to shoot your pants that's all
that is it's the perfect storm the
perfect freaking storm but uh yeah so
Green Bay is about 30 minutes outside of
Appleton we went to Lambeau Field and
you got to see that now I am not a Green
Bay fan I'm an Aaron Rodgers fan he's my
favorite player
it's one a1b him and Cooper cup for the
LA Rams my favorite players so
um ah look at Nick a post I can finally
get behind that's right yeah that is a
old school Bart Star Jersey I was gonna
wear it today but I didn't unpack last
night and when I got it out of the
suitcase today it was a disaster so you
know you can't be all wrinkly on the
show but yeah Lambo is dope man
and they have you walk out of the tunnel
like the the you know the legendary
tunnel my problem with that is you walk
out of town they play like crowd noise
in the same music they walk out to so
it's like historic Lambo field but then
it was that song
I'm like what why would you why would we
walk out to this Mark was Way Towing it
because the the tour guy was like oh are
you ready Mike was like let's go I was
like whoa whoa dude Jill Jill it was a
fun time though man we had a good time I
can't imagine when it gets cold out
there and then I did a uh just modeling
pigs of Mark
um
that's cool the weirdest looking boy
band ever you ain't lying dude you ain't
lying old school Bart Star though Jersey
man when's the last time you saw that
the long sleeves pretty swaggy that's a
jersey a a rock even outside of uh
Wisconsin I feel like again not the
biggest Green Bay fan and they're
definitely a struggle this year and even
the tour guide was like if you look up
there it says whatever the last time
they've won it has all their Super Bowl
wins it's like there's three more places
2022 2022 2024 I was like in what world
are you living in you guys have
completely
destroyed the team you know you paid
Aaron Rodgers all this money which you
should but you give them no tools you
trade away his best asset how dare you
like we're going to be just as good it's
like how in what world you don't draft
anybody last time you had a first round
draft pick he drafted another
quarterback you know so he just pissed
off Aaron Rodgers
what can you do dude but I'm rooting
fearing Rogers but it's gonna be a tough
year for him but my Broncos play tonight
baby my Broncos play tonight what's
interesting about the Broncos
I've seen my team being from Denver but
one of uh the thick Boy network
employees George his brother who's uh
played at UCLA First Team all pack uh
12. he uh was drafted by the Denver
Broncos in the second round so he's
actually the second string tight end for
the Denver Broncos but he has uh messed
up hammy so I think he's out to week
five so it's not the way we'll start off
your professional career but [ __ ]
happens but yeah Bronco is going to
light up Seattle AFC West holler we're
crushing it but uh yeah shout out to
Appleton everyone's so nice out there
man shout out to Wisconsin
um back on the road back on the freaking
Road it is a busy week for your boy
doesn't can't stop won't stop can't stop
won't stop his P Diddy says sleeps for
the week and maybe says sleeps for the
week just isn't living life right I feel
like I wish I was one of those people
that needed only three hours I'm not
when Daddy doesn't get eight hours it's
a disaster and my face looks like this
if you're just listening to this and
you're not watching this on YouTube I
look like a Sharpay right now I'm a
Sharpay of a man my face is getting
fatter because I get no sleep and I'm
exhausted that's okay uh speaking of
tour dates so I have one show shoot
tomorrow night better figure it out shop
and friends just can't have some
monsters on their shopping friends some
big boy shows uh Trevor Wallace Sam
Tripoli and uh some other very very big
time monsters
um that's one show only at 10 30 at the
Hollywood improv Tuesday night September
13th and then the real thick Boy tour
starts uh back up this Thursday Friday
Saturday Ontario Inland Empire holler at
your boy Ontario California is this
Thursday Friday Saturday and then I end
September in Boston my favorite City
Boston September 29th through October
1st that is almost sold out then I'm in
San Jose Salt Lake City Utah in my faves
and then just announced we announced it
last week but I don't think we had a
show just uh coming in hot I haven't
been to Calgary in about four or five
years Canada your boy figured it out I'm
in Calgary Canada I think is Alberta
Canada Calgary I think so it says a b
right there that is Calgary uh Canada
right now one show only uh it's at the
rooftop downtown Canada Calgary baby
that's 414 3rd Street Southwest that
could be wherever I have no clue where
it's at I don't know it is Alberta it's
Alberta great grand wonderful at the
rooftop that's one showing that [ __ ] is
almost sold out when it sells out we we
will add another show so Calgary come
get some from your boy to get to
thickboy.com get you some uh let's get
into the fights man we had a crazy week
of fights first time ever uh the UFC has
had to deal with something like this uh
before we um getting to the chaos that
was UFC 279 we cannot continue the show
without mentioning uh this is news to me
I just found out about it when I walked
into the office uh this morning
a guy who was uh
um on the big round breakdown he was
always a fun guy we would text each
other go back and forth on Twitter and
stuff like that
um uh Elias theodoro uh passed away
apparently due to cancer
barely due to cancer man and uh this is
uh this is a tough one man this is a a
really tough one because uh you know
young handsome dude I had no clue uh
what's this say I'm hearing the news as
you guys are he was also
just a funny talented guy
um he was uh he wanted to be the first
male ring card man that was his joke
right and they let him do it a smaller
um Invicta yeah yeah and Victor let him
do it
um I had no idea man so follow initial
report from bjpen.com TSN reports that
Theodora was battling stage for liver
cancer
that his diagnosis was known to a few
Theodore 19-3 dude stud was a veteran of
22 MMA bouts including an 8-3 run in the
UFC he won The Ultimate Fighter all
right he beat Eric Anders Dan Kelly
Caesar Sam Alvey you know no punk no
punk at all along with fine Chris
Theodore was best known for being an
advocate for use of medical marijuana in
2020 the Canadian veteran became the
first fighter to receive therapy
therapeutic use for weed which was
granted by the British Columbia Athletic
Commission
there you go Theodore also made
headlines when he served as a ring boy
for Invicta FC event
Rodriguez Pro debut he started ain't no
um parted ways the promotion 2019 which
is weird because he was crushing it even
though yeah following the United
decision lost Derek Bronson which Derek
is a monster
um Theodore went 3-0 scoring enough
decision
yep event so he's five he wanted to
fight as recent as December last
December man
it's just so tragic it's uh his
hopefully his family's okay I can't
imagine what they're going through
hopefully they have a GoFundMe or
something for that which I will
definitely contribute to Theodore was a
special special dude was not uh on this
Earth long enough man we need more
people like Theodora and uh it's just
[ __ ] heartbreaking not the way you
wanna
you know find out when you come to the
office that is terrible terrible news
and then my heart goes out to his family
and friends and I can't imagine what you
guys are dealing with if there's a
GoFundMe or anything like that let me
know I'll contribute however I can help
you guys out man but that is just we
lost a good one man so rest in peace my
friend and uh
yeah man we love you here buddy so
hopefully you're listening this in some
capacity my man so love you let's move
on to the fights and try and get some
sort of Happiness out of this let's take
a little break from me chatting your
guys ears off then get right back to the
program because NFL's opening week was
action-packed my Broncos play tonight
baby but the Chargers look good rams
look awful Cowboys look absolutely
terrible but it's just getting started
don't throw your team out the bath water
yet they might be able to pull it out
and that's the NFL you never know get
ready for week two of touchdowns big
plays and even bigger wins with
DraftKings Sportsbook an official sports
betting partner of the NFL this week new
customers can bet just five dollars on
any football game you get 200 in free
bets instantly want more action cool
everyone can experience the thrill of
DraftKings early win promotion it's
simple this Sunday bet on any NFL team
to win if your team leads by 10 points
at any point during the game you get
paid instantly even if they lose as long
as you get up by 10 you win baby fight
fans DraftKings Sportsbook also has you
covered you got Corey Santa Hagin
fighting this week bet on my boy don't
forget about the highly anticipated
Trilogy happening in Vegas this Saturday
Triple G Canelo who do you think's gonna
pull off the trilogy I like Canelo but
also the prop bets where you make money
there all right with my friends at
DraftKings download the DraftKings
Sportsbook app right now use promo code
shop show that's Schaub show to get 200
in free bets instantly when you place a
five dollar bet on any football game
that's code shop show only at DraftKings
Sportsbook an official sports betting
partner of the NFL minimum age and
eligibility restrictions apply C show
notes for details see next page for
directions for disclaimer download
DraftKings Sportsbook app now use promo
code shop show now let's get back to the
freaking program psych we're not getting
back to the program because listen I'm
here to talk to you about Kratom listen
I fired my brain with Kratom before any
podcast or stand up it's my Limitless
bill I feel like Bradley Cooper I just
don't look like him they don't help you
look better but they help you think
better that's right the best focused
product I've ever used all right and
best part it's all natural baby it's all
natural that's what we want there's one
ingredient it's Kratom it's the purest
best Kratom you can get kratom's like
the CBD Market remembers the wild west
like I guess I'm gonna use this CBD well
now you can trust my friends at happy
hippo and if you visit happyhippo
herbals.com all right that's Happy Hippo
herbals.com use the promo code thick boy
you get 20 off for life you can use that
code as many times as you want that's
Happy Hippo herbals.com promo codes
thick boy 20 off for life for the best
Kratom ever
UFC 279
so uh for the first time ever you've had
a shuffling of the card and listen I'm
not a conspiracy guy I'm also not here
you know I'm not jumping on this
freaking mic in thick boy Studios to
tell you that the UFC was in on this and
it was this whole you know uh weird
conspiracy and all this stuff was going
on and they've always planned to do this
I don't believe in any of that
I do think there's something to be said
there's a few things that make give me
skeptical hippo eyes there's a few
things where I go huh that's interesting
so let's talk about those things uh
first of all the Daniel Rodriguez Uh
Kevin Holland fight being a catch rate
of 180 was always kind of suspect to me
because they've made guys uh take way
shorter no notice fights and cut weight
right so for that to be at 180 to me
there was enough time to do the fight at
welterweight if they wanted to but they
decided to a catch rate 180. okay I was
like I didn't think much of it
hamzat right who's the kind of the the
Catalyst of why the card got shaken up
uh in the first place hamzat
um he didn't miss weight he blew through
the weight he wasn't even close man so
there's missing weight when you have to
like half a pound that's missing weight
when you're 180 pounds you you didn't
even try dude and you know
he's a professional and he he's also not
a guy you know like this is no shade at
Tony Ferguson he's not a guy that puts
his camp together and you know he's he
runs the thing and what he says goes no
no omzai comes from like camp with
either as professor as it gets man so
when it comes to weight cutting there's
no way that guy was just you know not
doing what he had to get done to make
the weight and he's made the weight
before right so
we know he can do it and the way he
misweight to me
there's no way amzod who's fighting
ideas which is the biggest fight of his
career hands down Main Event right on a
pay-per-view biggest opportunities life
is going to come in 10 pounds overweight
at his level with the camp he comes from
and then people said that
um
he was out the night before at Wayans
you know eating and drinking and doing
stuff so and then also they said the
doctor checked in on him and Neil magni
a good buddy of mine trained partner for
many of years goes I've never had a
doctor come check on my weight make sure
I'm gonna do it that far out that's
strange he's like I don't know you know
so there's a lot of stuff going on there
and then also with hamzat when he missed
weight he wasn't like oh my god oh are
you kidding me he it was a joke played
it off
and then the UFC there's certain things
that you can get away with and they're
still going to play ball and you know
and promote you and put you as Main
Events and give you big fights there's
certain things you can get away with
being the bad boy I'm not saying homes
that's the bad boy but we'll get to that
I need to lean into that dark side but
there's certain things you do
um that's frowned upon but UFC's even
like all right whatever man but the one
thing you they do not eat compromise on
is when a fighter misses wait it's the
one thing man it's the one thing do you
see as zero tolerance for if your hom's
not you if we all know this everyone who
makes weight knows this if you're hamzat
you know dude that's a big [ __ ] deal
you didn't miss it by half a pound you
missed it by a significant amount of
weight and he had no [ __ ] given now
maybe that's a jet stand thing I don't
know
that's the only time where I've skept
the hip hip wise something's going on
there where it was agreed to way before
that he was going to come in 180 pounds
I think
I think also which adds to it now I
don't think this is a conspiracy in the
UC was like all right let's do this to
donating homside and Kevin Holland and
Daniel Rodriguez and leech and switch it
all about I don't think it's like that I
do think they were kind of trying to
figure things out
but there's some to be said where
the UFC and Dana said this I'm not
pulling this out of my ass but the UFC
knows how a pay-per-view is going to do
they know how it's going to sell before
it even the fights go live before the
first preliminary fight going into it
going into Wayne so you can see how it's
trending how it's tracking through all
the promotions can usually tell what I
think happened
again it's just my opinion I have no way
to back this up no evidence they're not
going to give me any of that
data to back this up which you know
sucks but whatever
um
I think that fans were turned off by the
UFC and especially Dana White in
particular his treatment of Nate Diaz
and the way that Nate Diaz has always
been you know kind of f the man and done
it his way and then he wants out and
people don't like the way he's being
treated and he keeps asking for fights
and they won't give him fights and then
they they just don't give him a fight
they give him the worst matchup possible
and I think fans and I said this on find
the kid a clip that went pretty viral
for me you know if you're an a DS fan
the way you
show the UFC that this isn't right we
don't agree with this and listen I love
Nate Dia as much as you guys do but the
way that you would the only way you can
affect the UFC's bottom line but then
you're not affecting Nate Diaz bottom
line so It's Tricky but the only way to
fight back against us don't buy the
Pay-Per-View
don't subscribe to it say we don't like
this because this was this was the this
match-up man when it started it was
whatever minus 1800 uh homside the guy's
like it made no sense in any facet I
mean to me it made me completely no the
pros cons there's so many more cons so I
think what happened and again the UFC
knows how pay-per-view is going to do
before the first fight happened Saturday
night the week of they know how it's
trending how it's going to go they have
a pretty good idea they don't know down
to a T please turn off phone they don't
know down to a t but they do know that
it how it's gonna be a success or not
and I think the backlash that Dana
received when as soon as this fight was
announced people were Fierce Fighters
are Fierce Dan Hardy who's a huge uh
figure in the space did not approve of
it a lot of people didn't agree with it
now of course you don't have your people
go you don't count Nate Diaz out I get
all that but I think for hardcores I'm
sorry not hard course for the general
fan they know Nate Diaz everyone knows
Nate Diaz he's famous [ __ ] they don't
know homzat but the only thing they find
out from Hamza is he's a chechnyan
monster who's he's not just a small
favorite it's going to be a Slaughter
and like oh that's not right so I think
if people can assume the outcome of a
fight they went I'm not interested in
seeing Dana White once again [ __ ] over a
fighter who's put his livelihood on the
line for him and so it wasn't trending
very well it wasn't trending very well
at all because you kind of knew the
outcome UFC [ __ ] up they overplayed
their hand they thought the audience was
it was Dumb and we're not dumb I think
the general fan is not dumb so I think
they went I'm good on that one I'm gonna
you're gonna do what today nah [ __ ] that
man I don't want to see that [ __ ] I we
respect Nate too much we respect Nate
too much so isn't trending well so
you'll see what we gotta come up with
something man we gotta come up with
something what can we do what can we do
and it just so happens
that Kevin Holland and Daniel Rodriguez
are at this weird catch weight at 180.
Palms out weighs in at 180. So Not only
was a complete Shuffle but it was a
perfect Shuffle not of one matchup of
three on the pay-per-view now to UFC's
credit when they did Shuffle it up it's
a better Fight Card a way better Fight
Card just happened the day before so I'm
still curious how this thing does you
know I I don't know the pay-per-view
numbers they're they're crushing it
they're making more money than ever but
you know a day's notice to to change
things like that I'm curious the
hardcores were in regardless nobody
cares but for the where they make their
nut is off the common fan so I'm curious
the common fan kept up with all it was
hard to keep up even at the for the the
staff here for thick boy Studios you
know Friday night I'm on I'm going on
and off stage doing the meet and greets
doing all that and I get back to my
phone out of jigillion attacks but
you're like oh did you hear what
happened to Hamza Kevin Holland oh did
you hear this then the other thing gives
me skepto hypoise with all this again I
don't think it's a big conspiracy I I
just think it wasn't trending well
they had this kind of as a plan B right
and it was a great plan B and they they
were able to pull it off if if the
audience weren't buying into it which to
their surprise we didn't buy into it
because we don't see anybody treated
like Nate Diaz was being treated so what
what else gives me kind of skeptical
hypoise is remember this all started off
with the weigh-ins and Dana gets on the
mic and goes for the first time ever we
have to cancel away and it's just it's
Mayhem they wouldn't have the security
it was it was chaos back there no doubt
chaos that makes sense yeah yeah well
also would you expect when you have guys
like Nate Diaz Tony Ferguson homside
Kevin Holland Daniel Rodriguez like you
you you're doing some wild boys man you
lined up on the you lined up this should
be UFC 279 [ __ ] bad boys like you
line up the dude to give no F's given
man and you guys everybody knows this
you know these guys can mouth off you
know hamzat and Holland have an issue
with each other you know Nate Diaz has
an issue with everybody you look at him
wrong he's gonna fight you if if you
were hired for show time to you know
promote Conor McGregor as a paid gig
he's not gonna enjoy that he's gonna try
and fight you even known you in Gucci
boots and tight jeans okay that's Nate
Diaz bro so uh you know what you're
dealing with is the point here
so those weigh-ins which I've been in a
significant amount of them over I don't
know 15 of them probably in big events
especially pay-per-views
you got to realize there's let's see one
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten eleven twelve thirteen thirteen
thirteen times two is twenty-six so you
have 26 professional fighters on this
pay-per-view card
each one of those 26 Fighters has a team
so you gotta realize they're all in the
back they're sitting because it's it's
it's roped off right so the fans can't
see the back there of all the fighters
and most of them especially there's only
a few heavyweights on this card I think
one heavyweight uh fight was on this
card right
yeah I think so so you so you have you
know you're one heavyweight fight but
for the most part everybody back there's
just barely getting by they're [ __ ]
their you know low energy
cranky freaking no nutrients depleted of
water they can't they just want to get
on scale and get out of there right but
yeah remember those 26 Fighters
have their Camp comes with them to these
weigh-ins so 26 let's say being friendly
and there's way more guys like this
let's say I have those 26 guys each
person gets three Corner men so 26 guys
26 times three is what I'm gonna do it
right now because I cannot do math
78 yeah 78 so just and this is just
being conservative you have 78 people
back there
team fight teams coaches nutritionists
and then you have the fighters
there's not much to do back there and
this is even when I fought then this was
before cell phones or you know people
are addicted to them like they are now
there's nothing to do everybody's on
their phone every single person in the
back of that weigh-in has their phone
Okay cool so you have how many days 70
some people 78 78 people with their
phones
let's just be conservative and say
freaking 50 of them have their phones
out which would be insane this day and
age in the cell phone age we live in so
50 people have their phones out
it was Mayhem it was crazy people's
heads were flying off freaking hamzat
freaking Spartan Kick Kevin Holland Nate
Diaz got involved and then freaking
Daniel Rodriguez and then Tony was upset
and Nate was throwing things and oh my
God we have enough security right right
where's the footage
nobody
nobody got anything
and then the build up to it they show
you this clip to show us the Mayhem did
did you see the clip they posted
that that's not May
maybe my definition of mayhem's a little
different than the UFC But You're Gonna
Cancel a Wane of a huge pay-per-view
over that it can't be the clip you
showed me there has to be more Clips out
there right
show me One Clip go Jim bring it up you
can't just saw a picture yeah like this
yeah it mayhem though man I know now
think about when DC granted this was
open to the public think about when DC
and Jon Jones fought remember that and
the little dudes in the middle and
trying to stop and [ __ ] terrified and
they're fighting how many Clips you see
from the fans there
unreal thousands thousands you're
telling me not one person got any
footage
nothing
zero zilch just that one post
to build up the pay-per-view do they
they aired on uh Saturday morning that's
it
I'm not buying it I'm not buying it now
do I think hamzat and Kevin here's the
other thing those 26 Fighters it's like
the JFK thing where calendar you know he
wants to uh you know his argument for
every conspiracies you think all those
people are in on it like no all those
people are not the main people who make
decisions are in on it 100 do I think
hamzat knew he was gonna fight Kevin
Hahn yes do I think uh Nate Diaz and
Tony Ferguson uh might have had an idea
yes
um outside of those four gentlemen the
four big boys that made the card nobody
else is in on this and now when I say in
on it I think UFC was like here's the
deal here's the deal this is what's
happening and Nadia said they offer him
a ton of money which great that's what
they should do
um
I it's just I I'm not it's not it's not
a conspiracy because this the the winner
out of all this is Nate Diaz Nate Diaz
one man so Nate Diaz he got to avoid
hamzat and again being an a DS fan if if
the world is working like it is and
rotating like it should there's not a
[ __ ] chance he beats homside dude the
way and I think Kevin Holland is a more
dangerous Fighter for Hamza way more
dangerous
way more dangerous so
for Hamza to go in there and I I don't
think he got touched destroyed Kevin
Hall insane dude at one you're like
Jesus Christ when he locked in that
[ __ ] joke
I think it was a was a dart stroke when
he locked it Darth was Anaconda to go
back and look but it was a dark so when
he locked in that dark stroke remember
Kevin hanza black belt for him to do
that are you kidding me dude this dude
is a [ __ ] Savage
and notice Hamza too no Fox given gets
on the mic I don't give a [ __ ] cause he
almost ruined the event but in actuality
he didn't the UFC knew this was
happening harms that news happened his
team knew this was gonna happen he's not
sorry for missing weight don't give a
[ __ ] what you think about him missing
weight Dana doesn't really care for the
first time ever Dana doesn't care about
a fighter missing weight
you know it to me it's just I get things
work out maybe this maybe maybe this is
the one time where you know it does look
like uh this just happened the UFC
pulled out and hats off to him but
it just worked out a little too well for
my like and did not question some of it
that's all I'm saying I think that
people the the general fans were not in
on this the treatment of Nate Diaz and
the massacre and watch Walking him walk
the [ __ ] mile walk to the [ __ ]
Guillotine and people like no no no no
no no no you don't want to do this
seriously we overplayed our hand man we
gotta switch this up Tony friction ideas
makes perfect sense again Nate Diaz won
Nate Diaz won so now
Nate is a free agent right he uh fought
his last fight in UFC and he's like I'm
gonna show those boys how it's done
outside the UFC you know everyone's
doing it wrong
but a lot of things Nate says you know
people like yeah right you're right man
he could say whatever and people like
you got this it'd be tough to do it
better than Conor did we can Floyd
Mayweather be very tough that was
unheard of you know so
um my hat's off to him and I think for
Nate Diaz and Tony Ferguson
um
I'll just call like I said again I love
Nate and Tony was it the best fight
we've ever seen absolutely not did one
look 38 and I look 36 absolutely the
difference between Tony Ferguson Nate
Diaz is Nate Diaz has adjusted the way
he fights he's obviously not going to be
a completely different fighter but when
you get older you can't use the same
Pace you can't use that the same tact
that you use when you're a young man at
26. so Nate's style and the way he
fights is really beneficial as you get
older Nate's never been the most
explosive never Nate's never been a guy
that just you know stocks and comes
after you it's a volume puncher back in
the days a volume puncher that wears you
out has a granite chin and eventually
he's going to get you
but he's adapted at his age where he's
not a volume punch he's not throwing a
million [ __ ] punches like he used to
he wasn't coming out like a banshee so
his style is predicated now and adapts
better the older he is and it works for
him now is he going to be anybody in the
winter weight division in the top ten
absolutely not no no he he you know he's
older men so for Tony Ferguson though a
guy who's very unconventional spinning
back kicks and rolling around the ground
explosive that style as you get older
can exist you can't do it it's not going
to work you can't be an older man at 36
or 37 what the [ __ ] he is and then still
try those same things when you don't
have that those young muscle fibers the
explosive Tendencies and you saw that
those spinning elbows and the the
spinning cake stuff we saw the mile away
Nate saw it a mile away you know Nate
saw that Nate saw a a [ __ ] mile away
so it for me it was tough to watch it
was was
it was a good fight you know it was just
it was a legendary fight it's no
different than watching Matt Brown it's
no different than we watch BJ Penn so
when people go well what do you mean
Miss what this this is what we thought
it was I didn't have time to think what
it was just happened I got an eight-hour
[ __ ] notice what do you mean it is
what I thought it was you know so
it was great that you know Tony and Nate
and it to be honest to be completely
honest it should be both their last
fights in the UFC I know Nate said I'm
gonna go do some things come back to FC
the only reason he comes he leaves that
door open and I think the UFC brass is
stoked about that because
for Nate when you think about his
options
you know his fight League thing coming
up but take that out that's whatever
that's gonna be very difficult to pull
off just for a number of reasons but for
Nate what would happen is this only adds
more value to his fight against Jake
Paul now so we all want to see Nate Diaz
versus Jake Paul Nick now Nate Diaz is
coming off a win he looked great he's
the Talk of the Town and you know he he
did outstrike Tony Ferguson Tony
Ferguson's leg kicks were effective Nate
even threw some like kicks but now you
know Nate coming off a win over Tony
Ferguson just adds more value to Nate's
brand and adds more value to the Jake
Paul Nate Diaz fight which we're gonna
get next
but outside that it's not gonna have a
professional boxing career come on
there's no way there's no way you can't
watch that fight on Saturday night you
go I want to see that guy fight a
professional boxer hell yeah dude and
the the and after watching that that
Jake Paul fight's gonna be tough man
it's gonna be tough for fighting you
guys think that's a tough fight for Nate
man Jake's young explosive hits like a
Mack truck another thing about that why
Nate won that night is that was Tony
Ferguson's first fight at welterweight
Tony is not a welterweight Tony is not a
big 155er he Tony was designed for 155
he's the perfect size for 155. he does
so much cardio he's a Savage with all
that stuff Tony at 55 especially in his
prime one of the best we've ever seen
Tony is not a welterweight Tony was just
at welterweight because he was trying to
fit he was lost he's trying trying to
get a win trying to figure something out
you could just tell Nate Diaz was much
bigger now granted Nate had you know won
The Ultimate Fighter 55 has a lot of
fights at 55. Nate now as he's older
he's a Nato one true 170. he's 170 all
day and he's a big [ __ ] kid man so
Tony Ferguson you know
the the fight against uh the leech would
have been better still a tough fight for
him but
you know he was so undersized in that
fight he would land stuff and just
doesn't it wouldn't have the same effect
that did when he was at 155 so Nadia's
being bigger eventually warm out Tony
first and his team tell him to shoot I
thought was strange you know especially
that late into the game they ended up
getting choked
um you know with 209 209 as they said
that's what they that's what the
pictures say but I mean it actually went
a little longer I mean stop at 209 but
look he sunk there choking at 209 it's
like boy you guys are reaching I would
love for that to be real though yeah
awesome but boy are you guys reaching I
know I was listening to some other
analysts talking about yeah like he even
choked him at 209 this is Destiny it's
like
I watched the fight twice that wasn't at
209.
I know what you guys are doing oh you
guys paused it so it looks like it
happened to him it's actually after that
but fair play whatever
um
but I think both guys should be done
you'll see now for again for Nate his
when you think about his options
Nate talks a ton of [ __ ] right a ton of
[ __ ] about the UFC which is why we love
it right he's the one he slapped Dana
White which is hilarious didn't him have
had his issues he's has issues with UFC
brass he's had so many issues they're
going to try to penalize him by giving
them homs up which didn't end up working
in USC's favor and actually worked in
Nate's favor and got the win and stocked
so big right now but when you look at
Nate's options and when Nate goes yeah I
still want to fight an MMA
well what options would he have outside
the UFC UFC's I mean again my point is
Nate talks all this [ __ ] have you ever
heard Nate talk [ __ ] about fighter pay
ever
asked for compensation I'm not come say
enough I'm Nate's making bank dude
Nate's making money a lot of money he
said he made so much money he didn't
know how much he made for this fight
now that to pay him more because the
game 21st cents different fight than
homsat which Romney is saying like we're
gonna pay you less right because easier
to fight but
um you know you've never heard Nate Diaz
go at the UFC about fight or pay or
you're raising the fight or pay ever
you've never heard him talk about man
I'm not paid enough to do this but never
they've always hooked Nate up his fights
against Connor he could retire now I
would imagine
he's not one of those guys that flashing
driving [ __ ] Lamborghinis and has a
house in Newport what's that Nate Nate's
straight when it comes to financial
Nate's good you've never heard him
question the UFC about pay because
they're taking care of the big boys he's
a big boy they're taking care of him so
you've never heard him question fight or
pay let's take another little break I
gotta play I gotta pay all these thick
boy employees around here man they don't
work for free but it is NFL season kids
it's week two baby week two room for my
Broncos once again and the charges which
is weird to say because the same
conference but I have to watch the
Chargers out here only team on TV all
the time listen you can watch week two
of the NFL season with my friends the
official sports betting partner the NFL
this week new customers can bet just
five dollars on any football game at 200
in free bets instantly instantly you
want more action say less everyone can
experience the thrill of DraftKings
early win promotion it's simple this
Sunday or Monday the all right you can
bet on any NFL team to win if your team
leads by 10 at any point during the game
you get paid instantly even if they lose
all good as long as you get it by 10 you
win it's that easy all right fight fans
you got Corey Santa Hagen fighting this
Saturday bet on that you got Triple G
Canelo bet on that make Bank bro
download the DraftKings Sportsbook app
right now use the promo code shop show
to get 200 on free bets instantly when
you place a five dollar bet on any
football game that's code shop show
schab show only at DraftKings Sportsbook
an official sports betting partner the
NFL minimum age eligible restrictions
apply see show notes for details see
next page for direction of disclaimer
download draftking Sportsbook app right
now use promo code shop show all my Bros
out there I'm worried about your wieners
that's right and it's time to bring that
same summer heat right into the bedroom
Summer's ending but the heat doesn't
have to stop because you can get
confidence in your life with my friends
at Blue chew that's where they help you
out inside the bedroom they're not there
you know watching do you thing no
they're not there they're just a
supplement to your bedroom game because
they're all they care about is your
wiener and your wiener living its full
life man Bluetooth is a unique online
service that delivers the same active
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis but
it's in chewable tablets fraction of the
cost take them anytime you want day
night plan ahead or when it's time to go
chew that little tablet and you're going
baby it's super simple sign up at
bluechoo.com all right and then you
consult with one of their licensed
medical providers once you're approved
you'll receive your prescription within
days so you're not waiting a long time
to get that wiener game up best part
it's all done online no awkward
conversations with the doctor you're not
waiting line at the pharmacy for these
wiener pills all right blue chill
tablets are made in the U.S of a
prepared and shipped direct your door
discrete little package all right we got
you covered man so if you could benefit
from a little extra confidence we all
can when it's time to go when your lady
or man's are raring to go Blue chew can
help chew it and do it baby and I guess
special deal for you guys is try
Bluetooth free when you use promo code
shop schab all you have to do is pay
five dollar shipping that's
bluetooth.com promo code shop to receive
your first month free visit
bluetooth.com for more details important
safety information and I thank Bluetooth
for being part of this podcast now for
reals let's get back to the program
so when you think about outside of the
UFC who's going to compensate them more
than the UFC I don't think there's any
organization that's going to pay more
so don't make much sense as far as
taking more MMA fights you have the Jake
Paul fight this one this this how I
think Nate's career goes
I would bet a lot of money on this he's
gonna leave the UFC he's gonna fight
Jake Paul I'd say in the next six to
eight months you're gonna get the Jake
Paul Nate Diaz fight he'll make a ton of
money off that
when that fight gets announced I'll
break it down that's a tough fight for
Nate win loser draw he's making more
money he's ever made in the UFC doing
that
I think so
after that I think he does go back to
UFC inside signs a one fight deal to
fight Conor McGregor in the trilogy and
that that's it that's it for Nate that's
it so I think what Nate Diaz is doing
now by leaving the UFC he he's basically
waiting for Connor to get his [ __ ]
together so he can come back to UFC and
fight him in a Trilogy fight and then
rifle and make more money than God and
ride up in the sunset so if you're a
Nate Diaz fan I think you have two
fights left in his career and they're
the biggest paydays he's ever gotten
you're getting Jake Paul and Conor
McGregor both up in the air fights both
fights he could win both fights he can
lose he's gonna be 0-2 or 2-0 you know
what I'm saying so they're both big
money fights big name fights and uh I
don't know what Conor's deal is with the
UFC but a part of me thinks you know
Conor The Mastermind that he is but him
and Dana have been good you know
there's rumors out there like yeah
Nate's getting out of it and the college
guys Contracting to put on that trilogy
fight on their own promotion that's why
Nate has his own promotion to do on his
own promotion and then they're cutting
the UFC out I think that's a bad idea I
think it's a bad idea I think it being
EFC and having the UFC you know machine
behind it is the way to go
um I actually end up thinking they'd
make more money doing that because if
you wait too long you're not going to
make much money you still make money
people always want to see the trilogy
but if you wait too long you know you're
gonna be it's a bad example I was going
to say Manny Pacquiao I'm Floyd
Mayweather but that's like the greatest
pay-per-view of all time even though it
happened [ __ ] six years later and it
should have so for Nate and Connor I
think Nate Diaz is going to take a
little vacation and go make whatever 30
million dollars and box Jake Paul and to
be huge and probably be on Showtime and
then comes back signs one fight deal
fights Conor in the trilogy it's a
massive fight it's a hell of a fight
because they're both fighting exactly
who they should fight and that's it for
Nate and that's probably it for Connor
as well
that's how that story ends
and then also with uh to wrap this up
with with hamzat
um
he has to be the only guy who's
misweight by this much and his stock has
gone up you can't tell me after
swatching Hamza I get not taking a
single blow to the [ __ ] face body and
absolutely Molly whopping Kevin Holland
you can't tell me you don't want to see
him fight more you can't tell me that
and for Hamza you know he's getting
booed inside that hot gun because he did
you know according to the general fans
risked the entire card right which he
didn't but he's down to take this fall
you know I think in the UFC's and on
this too he's leaning into that bad boy
kind of look he doesn't give a [ __ ]
there's a lot of money to be made being
the bad boy ask Jon Jones ask Floyd
Mayweather two of the ones the best ever
in boxing the other is the best ever in
mixed martial arts they're bad boys
people are paying to see them lose
hamzat knows where the money's at harms
us not paying attention to your social
media Hamza doesn't give a [ __ ] if you
think he risks the whole card and is
unprofessional he does not give a [ __ ]
and there's a lot of money in being the
guy people hate on because they're
watching [ __ ] trust me
so for Hamza you don't give a [ __ ] cool
you hate him cool watch him watch him uh
fight the nice guy pay to pay him money
to watch him lose it's gonna be tough
for this guy to lose so if your homs
like you kind of have you can go two
ways
I don't think if he's too concerned
about him making weight
they didn't seem to give a [ __ ] either
and that's again that's why I've
skeptical hippo eyes on this thing
because there's the the one [ __ ] rule
that you cannot break as a UFC fighter
is missing weight because then you
become untrustworthy they put all this
marketing into the main event and you're
missing weight it [ __ ] them
no stayed no then Dan's not like we got
to make sure that we get to start this
is ridiculous he that's the one thing
that Dana is furious about dude Furious
most guys once they miswade they're not
a main event the next fight they put
them you know the the first fight on the
pay-per-view or they're on the prelims
they're gonna discipline you and make
you prove to them that you can make
weight in in order for them to back you
and put all this money into marketing
guarantee that doesn't happen thumbs up
guaranteed guarantee he's the main event
next fight probably at 170. probably
against Kobe Covington
that's the next fight it's Kobe Compton
you mentioned the whole way thing many
times before so I I get it yeah it's so
crazy so do you think this is probably
the biggest conspiracy thing that's
actually potentially true
what do you see I see to me like yeah I
don't know it's weird to get you know
I'm not a conspiracy guy unless I'm the
JFK thing just look into it I think
it's clear as day I mean come on now but
um you know the whole Flat Earth thing
lizard people all that [ __ ] I don't
subscribe to a lot of that it's fun also
conspiracy is a lot funner than the
truth if the truth is yeah man it was
chaos back there was no security we were
worried about the safety of the fighters
we had to cancel it's like man there's
been more stuff that happened at this
Wayne's than this and just cancel this
and maybe it's it could be part of the
reason now that they're with Disney and
Disney like hey man what are you what's
happening here you can't have this
[ __ ] [ __ ] bare knuckle you know
fighting in the back let's shut this
[ __ ] down like we have zero tolerance
for this Mickey Mouse does not like
violence we do not like violence we're
trying to promote Pinocchio with Tom
Hanks and he got [ __ ] guys ripping
each other's faces off and throwing
water bottles you know like imagine
where the weigh-ins where the press
conference Nate Diaz and Connor
they they were throwing [ __ ] a water
bottle they're throwing [ __ ] rain
energy drinks they're throwing Monster
full energy drinks we have them here
shout out to rain dude I throw one of
those [ __ ] things my arm's okay that
hits you in the face ain't nobody
fighting
there was no talk of cancer in the event
there was no talk of mixing up the event
that wasn't even a [ __ ]
that was even mentioned there's been way
stuff than this so again when it comes
to consisting I don't know Nadia's got
paid it worked out for him you know I'm
sure Kevin Hong got paid more Daniel
Rodriguez and and leech are you know
they were just you know Pawns in this
game you know so Dana did say he was on
record saying like no one got paid an
additional boost for the switch up but I
don't believe no I don't believe that a
lot of stuff hold on you're gonna go to
You're Gonna Go to Tony Ferguson they
they always pay you more this is why
yeah I mean yeah yeah of course yeah
[ __ ] guys over all the time but still
fans still support the team
um but with Tony Ferguson hold on let me
get this straight you want me to go from
fighting at 170 my first time against
leech uh three rounds to a five round
Main Event pay-per-view and save the
card and you you tell me they didn't
compensate them more
come on guys that's not real of course
that of course they come see them more
the I would a [ __ ] course they did
now harms I don't I don't know what
happened with homside that's where I see
the the one who knows exactly how this
all went down to Tom's up
get into it his team they know
play play the game well don't worry
you're gonna take a lot of heat for this
it's actually good for your brand you
get even more famous and he did exactly
what he had to do because if he
struggled with Kevin Holland like geez
this isn't his stock goes way down if he
went in there and Kevin Holland almost
choked him out or let's say one by
decision it's like back and forth even
though Kevin Holland's a [ __ ] monster
a more dangerous fight than he did you
know he went in there and absolutely
Molly walked and was like next
hom's I listen homs I could have fought
in 1823 the same time in one
and that is no disrespect to anybody on
that card
and then you're gonna pay him as a main
event against Nate Diaz this guy who's
[ __ ] done everything he can for the
organization and you're gonna [ __ ]
toss him to this chechny and Savage how
dare you if she went oh we overplayed
our hand people aren't feeling this now
we're not feeling it's [ __ ] up man it
ain't right
the idea is one in the end so again
conspiracy not conspiracy I don't give a
[ __ ] the fighters win on this one Hamza
everyone won on this one everybody Kevin
Holland's stock isn't any lower he's
fine he'll get another fight he wants to
be active he's like I need three fights
man if he can't give me three fights
here get me the [ __ ] out of here I'm
gonna fight way more let's go you know
that's exactly how I should deal with it
yeah guaranteed Tony first got
compensated Kevin Hong got comes again
for Kevin Holland
let me get this straight
you were gonna have me fight Daniel
Rodriguez for three rounds at a catch
weight
and now you want me to fight hamzat the
biggest Savage on the roster for five
rounds to save the card too so you gotta
realize too in those situations it's one
of the only times the fighter has the
power to do anything to ask for whatever
the [ __ ] they want it's the only time
they have any negotiating power because
if Nate Diaz Tony Ferguson hamzat and
Kevin Hall don't play ball they lose the
UFC loses their ass they put Millions
into marketing so if Nate Diaz goes oh
let's so let's play the game where Nate
Diaz and Hamza this has all happened
just by chance and nobody's behind this
and there's no conspiracy let's say that
it just happened well if you go to Nate
Diaz who is by far the biggest drops
power on the car by far the biggest star
power on the card without any ideas you
don't have much going on there homs
that's not there yet for the hardcore
he's there we're going to play the same
fight whoever I'll pay to see him fight
whoever but Tony Frazier has never been
a headliner it's been some Fight Night
headlines she's not a pay-per-view star
Kevin Han's not there homdot's not there
you so if Nate Diaz doesn't play ball
and they don't pay more
you don't have a card
so of course he made more money
they're all all of them had to agree to
this for it to be perfect and it's the
only time the fighter has any power to
go let me think about it let me think
about it I'll do it for this much and
you see says yes or no uh again to you
she goes well not that much right you
want to overplay your hand they go but
we'll give you this much okay deal we're
gonna save your ass and still fight
because again if there's no conspiracy
for Nate you take you're changing the
tune completely which is better you have
better chance to win this fight but
you're still let's say there's no
conspiracy and you've been fighting uh
hamzat who's a guy you know completely
different than Tony Ferguson on a day
notice no you gotta you gotta pay me
more man I'll save this and we they have
the power they have all the power
because UFC's going how much do we put
in the market 10 million holy [ __ ] all
right well we marketed one fight We're
not gonna get it and they can easily
[ __ ] on them go not not happening yeah
no not happening 21st seemed like nope
not happening you don't have a card
I guarantee they paid those guests
guarantee
guaranteed
bet my last [ __ ] dollar they all got
composite they all knew what was
happening
conspiracy I don't know worked out for
the better
worked out for the better I'm not a
conspiracy guy but just the just the
general rule how [ __ ] the fight game
works
it worked out for the better you know
yeah way better to have the the catch
rate thing was weird with Rodriguez and
Holland you know the whole way the
weekend lean up to it no footage from
the weigh-ins that was so chaotic they
were so scared for the first time they
couldn't even do the weigh-ins proper
come on man there's no footage that
after the entire Camp's back there
there's none it was that bad
was there uh was there a circumstance
where Hamza and Kevin Hall got into it
100 percent
and then did you see the video of Kevin
Holland and Darren till who obviously
Darren tells on hamzat's team and the
train partners and close friends did you
see them calmly chatting they're just at
the hotel
I guess a sort of an argument but not
really kind of nothing kind of yeah not
bad it is kind of crazy man listen
I'm not saying it's everybody's in on it
and they're pulling the wool over our
eyes I'm just saying and the guys made
more money and it worked out better for
Nate Diaz and homsat they both come out
[ __ ] winners out of all this
I'm just saying yeah very strange
yeah all right Jim but there were some
good fights on the card there's some
other fights oh good fights on the card
our boy uh the the original thick boy he
is the thick boy mascot in the UFC Chris
uh Barnett not to be confused with uh
that can be com not to be confused with
Josh Barnett Chris Barnett who also
miswade on the card
wait 267 happened he tried his best man
it's just not in the cards for that man
he was getting [ __ ] Molly what if I
dropped wobbled and then pulls it out I
don't know if you've seen this man's
social media I think he's gained 200
000 wow subscribers followers on
Instagram overnight
and if you go to it dude he's
he's like he's like uh Derek Lewis but
he can dance his ass off I would love to
talk to him give him my food truck
there's no way you can tell me that
Beast Boy Chris Barnett doesn't have
some sort of football background how can
you be that big and not get a footwork
footwork and he he dances like a [ __ ]
and sing member this dude can look at
him dance personality from the [ __ ]
roof
yeah he's so fun to watch look at him
dance yep
this year get this guy on the main card
he's too fun not to he's so fun yeah
he's so fun dude and probably he didn't
have a ride home
I don't feel safe
take advantage of me bro
it's a three minute long video but I
guess he didn't have a ride home so he
was asking people on his Instagram to
give him I'm a fan man maybe it's the
first sponsored athlete of thick boy
that'll be freaking dope
I mean this guy had to play [ __ ]
football there's no way you're over 300
pounds without foot working to play some
football because he's the ideal size for
a defensive tackle and uh I'm not the
NFL but at a college level and that
footwork is nutsos like you see him
dancing like what in the [ __ ] yeah crazy
athletic crazy footwork dude crazy
athletic all right Tim what else you got
all right I'm sure you know these guys
because you're an NFL NFL guy but so
Le'Veon Bell and Adrian Peterson had a
boxing match all this highlight Mark
showed me in the green room I mean this
can't be healthy for Adrian Peterson
also isn't he like one of the best
athletes or something
no hold up first ballot Hall of Fame won
the best ever running backs I played
against me in college when he's at
Oklahoma he beat the [ __ ] when you see
him in person like Jesus Christ dude but
both these men Le'Veon Bell and uh
Adrian Peterson when he looked that I
know it's so crazy
[Applause]
and he's out
appears
my my only thing with this like you know
how much money Adrian Peterson made
playing football
I don't know maybe maybe he's awful is
finances I don't know what's going on
then Le'Veon Bell signed some big ass
contracts man huge contracts when he's
with the Steelers you you're talking
about two two [ __ ] freaks man it's
nuts so when I it kind of when I see
this stuff
to me this is completely opposite of
what Jake Paul and Logan Paul does
especially Jake Logan maybe a little but
these kind of freak Show matchups I just
I used to need something to do they're
retired I just don't get it while you
sign up for this I don't get it
especially both these guys like even if
they were somewhat done with the amount
of money they made in their NFL careers
Le'Veon Bell was a monster agent Pierce
won the best to ever do it Heisman
Trophy winner MVP I mean nuts dude rush
for 2 000 [ __ ] yards in the NFL freak
I did hear the I think Le'Veon I think
it was I'm pretty sure it's Le'Veon Bell
that said that he wanted to take a break
from the NFL because he wants to do
boxing because it's such a one-on-one
kind of sport so he wants to test
himself there that's why he started
training for a while listen I get as far
as that something to do and like get you
motivated and get back in shape two
freaks man
it bombs you have to see it
um
imagine if like [ __ ] Joe Montana
Boomer says about each other or some
[ __ ] or not now damn right now and Joe
Montana
Casey likes it yeah Casey likes it
uh this was just okay you saw this
already but so I guess it's the first
time it's ever happened in the UFC or I
think anywhere a liver kick from the
bottom yeah I've never seen it right and
it lands perfect and when you get hit to
the body on your [ __ ] out it makes tough
people [ __ ] crumble yeah leave this
boom he okay so and most people go oh
like I bet a lot more people will be
trained to do this now it's like that
was kind of a freak out isn't it like
the chance vegan liver kick from the
bottom not good so you could waste your
entire [ __ ] camp training that chance
of Landing are not good so just hope it
happens but don't train for it you know
but that was pretty crazy to see uh
Georgie
keto uh keto George yeah keto George
sent me this
uh this is
Ann Essen Gibb
koing Austin McBroom I don't know much
about these guys Tick Tock or some [ __ ]
something like that yeah so here we go
[Applause]
that's it that was pretty much a little
knockout
I mean that was I mean I got knocked
down
see let's see if there's one see when
people see the Promise because anyone
can do this right you haven't Le'Veon
Bell you have Lamar Odom you have uh
Nick Young like you have these guys do
this like you know the problem with it
because you have the Jake Paul's the
world and you have these YouTubers tick
tockers doing it there's a big
difference you can't watch uh McBroom
Gibb where the [ __ ] hashtag Mick Broome
dude you can't watch them and then also
view Jake Paul in the same light like do
you know what do you know what
Woodly or [ __ ] any guy that Jake
Paul's fought would do against these
guys like it's that's the problem though
like the waters get murky when you when
you're comparing yeah these kind of
quote unquote circus acts
yeah just the fact that freaking Jake
Paul took on Tyron Woodley to me that
was nice yeah that was enough for me to
be like okay
Anderson Silva that should give you all
the respect in the world for the [ __ ]
guy yeah he has five fights he's
financially one of the greatest ever do
it just beat Julio Chavez [ __ ] junior
he was 50 and three no he's not his dad
53 professional boxer he beat the [ __ ]
out of him dude that fight wasn't that
close
then this [ __ ] I don't let me see this
so this is Nick Young versus Nick
Young's in the blonde horn
that isn't right in the morning yeah
they just look so messy yeah
it's just
yeah nothing like Jake Paul J Paul is
like legit I would say yeah just from a
Fan's perspective especially at the the
inexperience that he has like you're
talking
again in some form oh
what the hell it fell out of the ring
you've seen a professional thought just
kind of nosed eyes out of the ring no
yeah I don't know the rest of these
people but yeah I don't know any of them
so first for Nick Young
okay so this was interesting so
apparently
Kevin Holland apparently went for like a
touch glove before he fought shamayov
and people are criticizing shamaya for
not doing the touch glove and just going
for you know what the double leg or
singing Do they have a clip of it yeah
let me see so let me know what you think
[Music]
not gonna do that so hold on hmm Play It
Again
whoop boom yeah so he so Kevin Holland
definitely went in for the the yeah I
don't like it but again Bill's the nerve
of the bad guy doesn't it and but she
might have responding like dude I'm not
going in there to touch class I'm going
to to kill him to take you know take his
head off so but but but my only my only
caveat with that is that she might have
did do this in the end shot oh if you're
not gonna do it you shake your head you
go um like when I fought Matt Metron
we're legit friends one of my best
friends in the game you see him on
[ __ ] thick boy all the time huh I was
like gloves and he went like this and I
was like oh [ __ ] that's crazy now for
Kevin Holland like you guys talked all
that [ __ ] Kevin Han talked all that [ __ ]
fake gangster you know touching he's
from chechnya touch gloves to them
that's gay
you can't touch gloves you didn't touch
gloves no there's no touching he's from
chechnya they don't touch gloves buddy
you talked all that [ __ ] and then it's
apparently got
Spartan kicked backstage I mean you
think this guy's gonna touch gloves
again if there was that animosity if I
if another grown man kicked me in the
[ __ ] middle of my chest in front of
everybody and then they held me back and
it was chaos and people were throwing
[ __ ] you think they're touching again
this adds to conspiracy you think
they're gonna you would never be like
dude all good bro let's get it what yeah
yeah bro you kicked me in my chest
yesterday and now I can do something
about it for 25 minutes I'm not touching
your glove we're not touching gloves
but apparently kicked him in the chest
just nobody ever saw it I'm believing in
this conspiracy by the way I am but you
believe what you want yeah
I can go on more if you want JFK Jr
stuff
uh so did you think Legion link so I saw
the fight too Legion Ling and Daniel
Rodriguez did you think that Lee
probably got the fight he won it or yeah
so in this list I'm a huge Daniel
Rodriguez fan here's the thing it
doesn't matter what I think it doesn't
matter because the [ __ ] judges gave
to my boy Dan Rodriguez he won on to the
next
but if I take my bias hat off he
probably didn't win that fight yeah
and that was pretty crazy man like the
weight discrepancy Lee looks so small
compared him to yes the whole thing was
very strange but what do you think about
Lee's outfit here fire fire dude taking
a page out of sexy yama's book dude
that's true
yeah he looked pretty dope that fight
was in that I thought that fight would
be better you'll be honest it was kind
of boring yeah
yeah when they when they shuffled
everything I thought it was gonna be
more exciting for some reason but then
it wasn't as exciting as now that that
goes against my narrative that well
again my narrative is that Nate and
homthot knew what was happening the rest
of people just Pawns in the in the
machine so it for Daniel Rodriguez and
uh leech to switch
opponents on on less than 24 hours
you're gonna get those fights yeah those
fights aren't going to be better so
that's why I think that those guys
actually had no clue
hmm
all right so this is basically just Jake
Paul tweeting about
um Nate Diaz he had a few tweets a lot
of them are good so
he goes this is how you leave an
employer and become Your Own Boss when
they obviously choked out Tony and then
this is just says that the caption says
Nate Diaz says he's going into the sport
of boxing yeah I wonder who's gonna
fight yeah yeah he's going into this
I wonder if we should pause it I saw
this video I don't like the way his feet
are pigeonholed it that's so what's
weird I saw the same thing I'm thinking
why is he doing I was like where's his
feet like yeah but why don't you just
straighten your feet you know I don't
know baby you're young man I'm an old
YouTuber here even I know them Optics
man you're feeling all pigeon holding it
was interesting to see uh yeah not much
to that but I mean he says a lot of good
stuff about um Nate so ufcpr team UFC
UFC PR team to Media attendant post vice
president do not ask our boss Dan about
Jake Paul Anderson Silva he's very upset
at Jake if you do you will have your
immediate credential revoked it is a
[ __ ] Legend would have slapped
the [ __ ] off hamzat good news Nate Diaz
official as a contract here's the thing
when again when it comes to Nate Diaz
and pursuing this professional boxing
career he's fighting Jake Paul he's not
gonna fight real yeah professional
boxers yeah
yep
all righty and here's the thing would
Nate Diaz uh slap harms out sure yeah
yeah I bet I bet he'd slap him yeah
wouldn't be him in a fight no yeah I'm
with you I think he slaps him no doubt
with all that chaos happening I bet he
was trying to slap him but inside that
steel cage where it counts
Nate ain't slapping them
yeah I'm just a beast dude
all right your boy Patty pimblet he uh
recently just talked about he does
suffer from depression right it may be
food to his Outlet
[Music]
my fiance all the people close to me
said I've said it plenty of times out
them I don't even know if I'd still be
here now I've had some dark times myself
flat and I've questioned a lot of things
in my own head do I do this do I do that
uh I might not be here if it wasn't for
all those people close to me I asked how
a person suffering from mental health
issues can help themselves the bad
expanded on his advice I've reached out
to your friend Jay I need a good
foundation around you man uh you know
the saying get it off your chest it's
real at the end of 2018 I got a proper I
was in a proper bad place lad proper bad
place just waking up crying every
morning the misses would get up and go
to work I just roll up and go to sleep I
was rolling over and just crying for
like an hour every day so I had to go
over that and get through it and had uh
to speak to people it's good he's
bringing attention to this yeah so I
remember his uh his close friend Pat
like yeah he committed suicide and he
was like if you're a dude and you want
to be you know you want to be macho you
don't want to talk about all your you
know stuff that you're dealing with so
he's like just talk to people and then
you could potentially get through it 100
yeah good for him man yeah
so that's good that he's putting that
message out there right now
uh I thought this was interesting as
well so I saw the salaries for UFC 278
Kamara Usman
made 500 000 obviously the paper
viewpoints I don't know all that stuff
but so he made 500 000 and then Leon
Edwards made 350 000 which I think is
low for
a title fight you know so I don't know
Costa 130 000. yeah but I mean you you
don't make money until you
um you know be until you become Champion
you make like [ __ ] you money when you
defend the belt and get pay-per-view
points the pro yeah the UFC takes them I
guarantee you Camaro made way more than
that okay Leon Edwards I guarantee the
email bonus he made way more than that
no she don't see those guys complain
about I know I pay they don't yeah uh so
anyways Holocaust I made 103. I thought
that was super low for Acosta I don't
know I think he's such a big figure in
the sport yeah uh rockhold made 200
which is cool yep
and he lost yep but he's a legend
obviously
oh yeah anyways yeah it was just
interesting to see the the top two guys
make that much money
I thought they would make more
all right
um I'm sure you already know this
because you're close to Chandler but
it's official now it's already it's been
in the talks that's Emporia and Michael
Chandler but it's official now uh MSG
November three why is it only three
rounds
and then Chandler signed a new uh fight
deal with the UFC making bank aesthetic
power yeah is that a new deal that's a
great I'm excited for that fight it's a
great fight I can't wait can't wait
it's gonna happen in New York right well
so it's not the three rounds really yes
so that means it's not the main event
three rounds
you know the main event right guys right
Jon Jones I wish um next month or so
yeah announcement from John oh that'd be
dope man I'm telling you this fight has
Main Event written all over it huh you
tell me that's not moving my Square gun
who could be bigger than that I'm
surprised Jon Jones baby I'm so
surprised it's still three I'm not means
it's not the main event means that main
events can be a banger and the only one
the only one bigger than them because
the main event's gonna have to be
massive to beat that yeah who's more
massive so I'm with you but Josh Jones
even with other fights even it's not a
title file they'll still do five rounds
sometimes so this would be a good five
round five but yeah I wish it was five
rounds but when I see it's three I'm
like oh they're oh I know what's
happening here
you're getting the Jon Jones effect
that's going to be amazing take all my
money this is another crazy one so
Darren till is going to be fighting this
badass up-and-coming triggers duplexes
um
boy Taylor needs a [ __ ] win right
yeah so this is Till's record as of now
yeah he's lost four as last five yeah so
not the best and uh drikas is on a what
five fight winning streak it's a good
matchup for till though yeah I still
root for till man of course man yeah you
hope he figures it out I think there's
some mental health stuff there as well
one hundred percent yeah all right so
Chiago Santos no longer with UFC signed
with pfl good for him
must get paid it's smart move too you
see his last fight you know like his his
fight with Jamal Hill you know him
getting starched
at that level where he's at you're never
gonna be champ at 205 go make money with
uh pfl and fight you know lesser Talent
that's the move all day proud you can
make millions yeah proud of him man
all right so this was interesting this
is uh I think during 25 years crazy I
know
and he dyed it so it looks even crazier
but uh so this is him and Li jingling
saying what's up but then you remember
Tony had that incident before we tripped
over cables yeah and then messed up his
name was that Fox Sports and so check
this video out
so Lee's pretty much dude be careful be
careful and yeah she did trip on a court
yeah leech seems like a good guy man he
was super awesome guy yeah I like leech
yeah
to kind of [ __ ]
but he still he's in the best movie
possibly yeah and it was a catch way
hopefully
you know put him down on the rankings
yeah no he's dude
he did awesome so
all right so this is an idea's uh post
five press conference I just played for
you Tom's dad's fight
no man is Chained can I yeah I was
watching another warming up
what did you make of his performance
lame scared boring rookie
white [ __ ] lame
dick sucker
all the all those in it did you watch
homes
to Hamza yeah he says the dick sucker
fight Jake Paul and come back and fight
homicide dude I know oh this is so
jacked up so I don't know how real this
is but so well it's real because you
have an opportunity posted this yes yeah
so while we're watching now if you're
just listen to it so
um Walker who's coming off a huge win
Johnny could break it for him for Johnny
Walker versus Cuda Libra whoever I think
loser goes home they're probably gonna
cut the loser cue the Libra so all the
pressure's on him he wins the fight but
now I'm guessing because covid protocols
they don't let you hang out in the the
locker room anymore they want they don't
want as many people in there so you'll
see a lot of guys still wearing masks
which is insane but uh so apparently
that I came in you going
even though you already fought though
like I know no no it's nuts if you have
so they they kicked them out and and he
was walking the street Barefoot Barefoot
to the hotel with his gloves still on
Johnny still has his gloves on I didn't
get a chance to get changed
to come back [ __ ] I didn't think
my gloves are here oh he's in the like
in the front holy [ __ ] that's
embarrassing yeah I mean he must look
badass too though yeah kind of it's more
embarrassing with the UFC I don't think
Dana or the UFC brass had anything to do
with this they you know it's just people
probably taking their job way too
serious you know like sorry man you
gotta get going but I guarantee if Dan
break what the [ __ ] you doing no he's
not leaving he needs to change yeah does
he have to leave like this is so stupid
when you say that people taking their
jobs too seriously I think especially if
you're like new to the organization yes
you probably just fine dude you're
probably stressed the [ __ ] out like I
don't want them to get mad at me and
then you did the opposite nice man
because now this is bad PR for them it's
so bad dude it looks terrible
uh I don't okay this is trippy to me so
Hezbollah you know he's like the
internet sensation still meaning khabib
yeah still so apparently he signed a
five-year contract according to a
reporter
uh I'm guessing he's a Russian reporter
but he signed a five-year deal with UFC
I guess to promote stuff yeah because
he's such a big social huge yeah so this
is what Danny White said so the video
that he sent Dana White I'm coming up
with WFC so I post that with me on the
plane saying I'm coming to the biggest
post I've ever posted white said I have
6.7 million followers on Instagram 6.4
million people watch that video it's
[ __ ] crazy yeah it's he's just good
for the listen the UFC does a great job
staying current and knowing you know
what's trending and you know who can
show influence and post so they probably
paid him bank because if I don't know
how many followers he has but out of the
millions that he has you know you're
probably getting 50 Grand a post so they
paid him a significant amount of money
to you know promote the UFC in the big
cards for some reason so yeah so yeah
it's nice Dana's not Shadow band like me
so uh what does she got all right let's
see
um not that not that here this is uh
this is from Bellator I don't know when
this fight was though but it's just so
Up Kicks you'll see here
[Music]
[Applause]
boy
what the heel say to the face they got
[ __ ] up cake sandwiches figure it out
dude yeah that was pretty cool
and then I only got like one or two the
guy looks like Houston Alexander if he
got a hold of Sammy Sosa's lotion
what else you got
foreign
so this is
this is uh Raymond Daniels yeah we're
just talking about a fight companion
yeah but so he you know he always likes
to be he wants to do flashy stuff
because that's his thing right so look
what he does here it kind of messes him
up I'll just show you
this is that karate combat pants are
sweet yeah
[Music]
no did he [ __ ] up his ankle
he did win the fight his neck's all
[ __ ] up he won the fight but he did
sort of knock himself out a little bit
during that thing
that's why the the crowd combat says oh
but you don't want to mess with the
karate combat pit yeah those slanted
walls
all right that's pretty much it um just
the fights
yeah you have a good fight night this uh
weekend so you have a fight night this
weekend with my boy uh the Sandman Corey
uh Santa Hagen and then you have song
Young dong which is a very tough fight
for Corey but of course I'm leaning
towards uh Corey Aurora's fine it's the
best town we've had let's see he's only
lost the the upper spare of the bandwid
division losing a Peter Yan then the TJ
Dillashaw fight chin thinks he actually
won that fight I do think he lost that
fight which pains me to say that but he
did lose that fight with the weird
giving up his back all the time so
um either way you know he's only lost
the you know he's lost the current champ
Al Jermaine Sterling which was a rough
night from the office they wins two more
Marlon uh Marias Frankie Edgar you know
that flying knee and then TJ Dil shawson
boots and he won they lost Peter Young
so uh you know he's uh mentally he's as
strong as they come man so I refuse to
pick uh against him against song Young
dung that being said not a crazy fan of
this matchup if you're a Corey sanhagen
fan and I'm you know I ride or die with
that guy so I think he gets it done
another fun uh knockout he's a wild boy
I don't think Sun young dung has faced
anyone like him
don't like the match-up though that
being said but of course didn't hang via
TKO something flashy that's what I think
it's done but sung young dung is a
[ __ ] monster monster man rushcard's
okay
it's all right yeah Andre feelies on
there that's cool yeah it's a fight
night you know
[Music]
it's a fun one too but all the fight
they'll be good there's no one's gonna
blow your [ __ ] hair back through our
star power but that's a great main event
and then you also have one flying under
the radar Triple G Canelo the trilogy
both a little both a little older Canelo
he looked pretty good in his last fight
I'm sorry Triple G look pretty in his
last fight Canelo was just by enough
more than he can shoot kept moving up
and wait until he met his match and the
guys are just too big for him up there
so uh I think it all gets this done I'll
say I think he actually uh it's boxing
I'll say decision Canelo uh majority of
decision but I think age is gonna catch
up with Triple G here I'll take uh
canola and that's a Saturday night on
The Zone I can't believe the Zone's
still around and I will be watching all
of this from The Green Room in Ontario
California I'm in Ontario Ontario Improv
is this Thursday Friday Saturday let's
go Inland Empire and then after that
September 29th through October 1st is
Boston that's almost sold out so get
your tickets now Thursday two shows
Friday two shows Saturday laugh Boston
that's Boston Massachusetts if not to be
confused with Austin all right if you're
a fan of the movie road trip if you
remember that Tom Green uh then San Jose
Salt Lake City in October and then I end
October I end October in Calgary Canada
October 27th and one show only at the
rooftop there we will add another show
once that sells out and so we're getting
close so on now it's the next show there
in Calgary but Calgary is October 27th
at the rooftop but this weekend The Boy
tour coming to you and we will have in
person the mic stud uh thick boy collab
you can always won't be available online
for me if you want online I think Mike
Stud but they sold out so they're going
to restock it soon but if you want it
this Thursday Friday Saturday Ontario
will be in person the uh Save a Horse
Ride A thick boy t-shirts and hats will
be available in Ontario California this
Thursday through Saturday and will also
be available in Boston until we sell out
so get you some see you guys this week
in Ontario also once or Tuesday night 10
30 show Hollywood improv shopping
friends give me some monsters come get
you some tickets at thickboy.com
That's it man let me know what you think
about the conspiracy again of the
biggest conspiracy guy but a little
fishy for me all right love you guys be
nice to each other stay safe see you
next week we're out